the Joe Rogan experience I'll see myself
dying like George Carlin in a hotel room
in Vegas somewhere in between shows I
don't think I'm gonna quit it's too much
fun and I miss it I miss it so much he
stuck with it that guy had crazy highs
and crazy lows
he had all the highs of like you know
occupation pool and class clown then I
saw him in the 80s at the Warner Theatre
and he was kind of flailing a little bit
like a mouse cuts his way and then he he
was trying out these new concepts some
worked some didn't he ended with the
seven dirty words because you know I got
it in my show then he came roaring back
with that the one about the earth the
earth is not dying we are what room is
this you know because I think he thought
maybe I'm done like maybe I'm a relic
and no he stuck with it and then he came
roaring back and you can always do that
I got a chance to see him in Hampton
Beach Casino in New Hampshire yeah when
I was I mean I I think I was twenty
something like that 20 or 21 and I took
my roommates to see him and he bombed
yeah it was a weird time for his career
it was one of those weird moments where
he had this routine that he was working
on where he basically say [ __ ]
everything he would say [ __ ] Israel and
[ __ ] comedy clubs he like he had this
list of things that he was saying [ __ ]
too but it didn't I think he was just
going through a lot of weird stuff in
his life then there was some substance
issues that he had had he'd have money
problems of the IRS owing too much money
to the IRS there was a lot of [ __ ] that
was going on in his life at those times
and also I think that he was a little
bit freaked out by you know he had
opened the door him and Pryor especially
in terms of language and subject matter
and now here's people like Sam Kinison
and Andrew Dice Clay coming along and
and Chris Rock that are pushing it even
further in both good and bad ways and
he's like do I even [ __ ] like run
either they need me like like I think
there was a couple years where he felt
like am i John Wayne at the end of the
searchers I've rescued everyone and I've
helped progress the world but I do
along in the world and then I'm just
gonna walk away into the desert there's
always that open up like sometimes your
bravery helps bring about a world that
ironically you don't belong in anymore
mm-hmm and it's such a weird I mean I
feel like that's what happened to Joan
Rivers at the end of her career she
broke so many goddamn barriers for women
and for talking about certain subject
matter and then at the end of her career
she suddenly saw all of her stuff get
parsed by this new generation that's
like this this generation that's
attacking her and parsing her stuff you
were enjoying the freedoms you're
enjoying partially because of the [ __ ]
that she did a barbed wire you could run
across it and then pointed her for not
using the correct language I mean yeah
yeah not just not the correct language
but deciding what she can and can't joke
about and I love the fact that to her
dying day she enjoyed a walk she was
like I'm not apologizing for [ __ ] this
is what I do I make fun of things and
I'm gonna make fun of you and I make fun
of me and I make fun of my family [ __ ]
you and she she held on to her guns
forever man forever she never never let
it go never let it go never shifted fear
this happen that'll happen to all of us
at some point there will be another wave
of podcasters that won't understand the
stuff that you and meirin and people
like that did podcasting wise and we'll
do it and look back at you guys like
what are you even talking about psyche
the reason you're doing what you're
doing this cause of the [ __ ] that we
laid down like it'll happen to me as a
comedian it's happened to um filmmakers
everyone's [ __ ] on Martin Scorsese
for going not a fan of the Marvel films
he was he never said don't go see them
he's like they're not for me like you
[ __ ] you wouldn't have your
horrible film if score says he hadn't
done his movies yes although these are
what made the guys who direct your
movies you like go I want to do that
right like you get to be he gets to have
any [ __ ] opinion he wants well in the
oven also what's wrong with not liking
certain things like I have very good
friends who like things that I think are
terrible I still like them like you're
allowed that if you don't like I have
friends who hate more
comic movies I [ __ ] love them I love
comic book movies and I have friends
like I'm not watching that stupid [ __ ]
that guy is definitely gonna live you
know nothing's gonna happen he's the
hero like listen man I get it I
understand how you feel a certain way
but the other thing about film to think
about a guy like Scorsese where he needs
to be put in much a much better
perspective is that when you think about
some of the stuff that he did in like
the 70s what movies had only been around
for like real movies for like 40 years
like King Kong like the 30s and then
here you go 40 years later you're
talking about some of those Scorsese
movies or the Coppola movie is like
Apocalypse Now like think about how
crazy that movie is when you really stop
and think about when it was actually
created and how what a short-time films
had even been made like that yeah and
and how crazy the execution of it is
it's like well when I when I hosted the
Independent Spirit Awards the year I
hosted it in 2014 it was the 50th
anniversary of John Waters first film if
you may but he was a teenager in
Baltimore it's called AG in a black
leather jacket and it's about an
interracial wedding being sited over by
a Klansmen it's a Klan for marrying an
interracial couple that was he shot it
off his parent proof in Baltimore in the
60s and I would told the audience like
this is the 50th anniversary of John
Waters first film any of you guys are
like oh we push you too far are we going
too far he's already done all that work
for you [ __ ] go for it he was an
openly gay teenager in 1960s Baltimore
shooting an interracial wedding on his
parents roof with a Klansmen doing the
ceremony do whatever the [ __ ] you want
it's okay that's so perfect yeah it's so
beautiful yeah
[Applause]